cing to all of us and I look forward to
Anon St thank you thank you everyone I'm
not sure it's going to appe it's going
to be fun for everyone but I will try so
please stop me whenever you don't
understand something or if you already
have heard this one before so this is a
recent work I did with um my student
Lorenzo and other collaborators
Alexander sladic stepan mangle Martin
trap AR Solin and Nicola
JIS so
um and I'm Antonio and I have a BL in
Edinburgh called
April and April for today is going to
stand for essentially about probability
reasoning integrals and logic trying to
appease both
communities so what I would like to talk
about is introducing this concept of
notations and
negations in probability uh land and
therefore this translates into
subtracting probability masses or
densities in mixture models I will show
you how we can take these models with
these negative values with these
subtractions and translate them into
deep circuits that we're going to
square why we're going to do this it's
going to be revealed later on then I
will use this model class to connect it
to other model classes that apparently
are very different in terms of syntax
and in terms of like uses they are um
emerged from other fields like kernel
optimization and quantum
physics and I would like to review which
kind of inference routines are tractably
supported by this model class this deep
subtractive mixture
models I will then argue that they might
be more expressive and try to talk a
little bit about the theory behind this
and very briefly touch some open
problems related to this field um and
these model classes that are quite new
at least to
me okay so this this is my promise so if
you don't sleep or don't sleep too much
or you don't think too much about lunch
I hope that you're gonna um find couple
of this thing interesting so I'm gonna
talk about a circuit lower bound some of
you in the theoretical Community might
find this interesting I hope or tell me
for example this is known or this might
connect to these other interesting
things and then I hope to expose the
theoretical computer science Community
to connections with the probabilistic
ones pgms and we already have been done
this through this great um seminar these
days learning and mixture models of
course for the machine learning people I
will introduce this new trackable model
class to play with includes ingredients
you already know about but hopefully can
open up new learning and representation
perspectives and I will also show a
simplified way to represent at least on
paper or on slides circuits and deep
circuits and this I found it's a very
simple way to explain
algorithms that happens on that okay so
this is the plan for the rest of the
talk okay let's start with the
subtractive mixture models so how many
of you actually know what a mixture
model is because this St can go really
wrong if I I don't make sure that we are
on the same
page okay many hands raised so I do
believe that the theoretical computer
science people left for lunch that's
okay
so so mixtures are so beautiful and so
fine and they appear basically
everywhere in machine learning and still
nowadays are used everywhere from
computer vision even to language speech
and so on so forth why is that the
reason because they allow you to model
complex distribution by utilizing
simpler distributions for example in
this picture you just pick three simple
gaussians then you put them together and
then you have a distribution that is
more expressive than the single um
gaussian
components how do we do this well the
canonical way to represent a mixture
model or at least what we find usually
on textbooks right on the bishop for
example is this one so my mixture
model is defined as a convex combination
of K components that are some other
functions in this case they can be
probability masses or probability
densities defined over some possibly I
dimensional space when I said convex
combination I mean that we do have some
constraints over these parameters here
so one constraint is that these
parameters needs to be non- negative and
they need to sum to
one now the second part is really not
that crucial because you can renormalize
someh but the first one truly
is why is that the case because if we
really want to have this very cheap rule
to distill a complex distribution from
simpler distribution
then as long as these guys
are valid probability masses or valid
probability densities and these guys are
positive then also this guy is going to
be an unnormalized density or mass okay
so that's the super simple ingredient of
mixture models keep this guy um in mind
I like to call this model additive
mixture models just to make it
distinction with the subtractive version
I'm going to introduce in a bit so in
Robert's talk you already saw how to
translate them into the language of
probabilistic circuits or PCS right let
me just reiterate a little bit more
because this is yet another slightly
variation of the circuit languages that
you have been exposed to through this
seminar right just to see that we are on
the same page so to translate the
example for the G and mixture model that
we saw before we have three compon
components C1 C2 C3 I'm going to
represent them as circles as input units
and these input units are going to
essentially encode probability densities
okay you can remove gaussians and you
can put whatever you want even a small
neuron Network right so that's first
part then we're going to connect that to
a sum unit and this is going to be a
weighted sum unit so these are our
weights we are assuming this weights to
be um non- negative okay so we read it
this in the feed forward way so we fed
some observation values for the three
gussian components we read out their
PDFs we mix this real numbers with the
weights and then we read out essentially
the PDF for the for the gaussian mixture
component for that point if I have to
look this into the circuit language what
are the properties of this circuit here
specifically so this is a suun and this
suun is move because all the inputs
essentially are defined over the same
set
variables then there there are no
product units here so it's a very
trivial case of a decomposable circuit
and even structure decomposable right so
for now forget about products they're
going to come into play when we are
moving to deeper circuits but these are
the kind of gadgets I'm interested in
right now okay so please ask questions
if this language is not clear at this
point so small shallow additive mixture
models Define the
circuit another way to call this kind of
circuit is to aonic and this comes from
the fact that these weights are non
negative now mixtures as I was saying
allow us to model these complex
distributions and also allow to keep
inference tractable as long as your
input distributions allow for tractable
computations for example if they do
allow you to do
tractable marginalization or
conditionals then therefore the whole
mixture allows you to compute tractable
marginals and tractable conditionals
right and in the machine Learning Land
we also love mixtures because we say
they are Universal approximators what
does it mean well it means that if you
have lots of them if we in the limit if
we put the number K the number of the
components to the Limit then we should
be able to approximate arbitrary well
any possible distribution okay so let me
give you some example and this goes goes
a little bit also in the direction of a
possible answer to the question Scot had
in the previous talk so a good is a
mixture model to model complex
distributions right I'm not going to
claim these are real world models real
world distributions like the banana
distribution or the funel one but they
are definitely not gaussian okay so
let's play the game how many gaussian
components do we need to fit this
distributions well okay let me start
with two not a great job we need to
increase the number of components right
so I'm going to switch to 10 something
better the banana is a cage right it's
almost ripe but we need many many more
if we want to have like um somehow more
reasonable
feeding well this is I would say
expected in the sense that the universal
approximation holds in the limit right
so the whole point here is can we do
better and in a sense circuits already
ask this question because whenever you
have a circuit that encodes a deep
mixture model or if you want a
hierarchical mixture model you can
encode an exponential number of
components exponential in what in the
depth of the circuit
okay however even if we go with a
circuit that is monotonic just
increasing the small Gadget I showed you
before we're only allowed to add
components so adding circles here in the
picture the power of negation that you
know for example logic
translates in probability land with the
power of subtracting masses and this can
drastically reduce the number of
component that you care
about let's go to a even simpler example
not many circles just two circles right
how many GA do you need to fit this guy
here so if I use two and I fit a g
mixture model I get this I go to 16
better job but feels like useless or
well not really useless but wasteful
and the fact is that actually ideally I
would only need two components a larger
one or the larger Circle and I would
like to subtract the second one out of
it so from here I hope this is somehow
visible right so this is what a
subtractive mixture model look like so
you allow the weights of the mixture
model to be negative and in this way you
can subtract mass and you can subtract
densities right
so ideally this sounds like a good idea
and a good idea that can save us lots of
components but how many of well
spoiler you can save an exponentially
number of components and you can analyze
this in the language of circuit but I'm
going to reveal this only later on I'm
going to give you the nitty-gritty
details so please if you're interested
in this try to follow everything or if
you want you can start sleeping and I
can use the bell at the appropriate
moment to wake you up just for the for
the circuit lower bound
okay let me get back to this subtractive
mixure model let me give a little bit
more nomenclature and context so in the
land of circuits if I have to represent
this as a circuit I would call this a
non- monotonic circuit which are objects
that are very well defined in complexity
and in logic we are just taking this and
translating that into this dialect
that's the D probabilistic circuits
where your input can be whatever
functions you want as long as they are
tractable for your Downstream reasoning
task now what's the issue though if we
just arbitrarily introduce negative
parameters even in a shallow mixture
model how do we preserve that the output
of our small circuit that encodes a
mixture model is non negative and I want
it to be non negative if I want to model
a density or a
Mass for example here if I have two G
Gan can I always place the two gaussians
everywhere and then just make sure how
do I make sure that their subtraction is
a negative
value for Gan we know how to impose this
constraint so it's essentially we need
to place the variance and restrict the
variance of the component we are
subtracting and place the mean in a
certain way such that the circle for
example always fall inside the bigger
Circle if we play this carefully then
this we we can do a pretty pretty good
job for other distribution this is also
known for example WBLS statisticians
know this um however this is quite
limited to single components sorry
single parametric families for the
components and to components that are
homogeneous in statistical data type and
also to mixtures that are smooth so my
question for the talk is essentially can
we have a more General principle such
that we can allow this negative
parameters we make sure that the output
is always non negative we allow deep
subtractive mixture models I will give
you an initial um solution for this by
using non monotonic circuits that are
squared so the squared is going to be
the trick to preserve non- negative
outputs later on I would argue that this
kind of solution also has been known or
used in different variations in other
fields and I will connect these other
fields one of these field is the one
with positive semi-definite Kern um
models and the other one is tensor
networks for example
okay now how do I realize a nonmonotonic
circuit which for now I want to be like
smooth and of course
decomposable um
well I just keep a circuit here right
and now I allow all these parameters to
be whatever they want so every possible
value on the real line so what I'm doing
here is allowing also this output to be
negative okay so this is going to be the
starting
ingredient of this
construction then I'm going to take this
and square it so if I Square the output
of the circuit and therefore the circuit
the output is always going to be non-
negative
okay do I still have negative
parameters
do I get an advantage am I able to
subtract things or
not well to see this I just need to
expand the square so to expand the
square essentially I'm G to have not K
components but something in the order of
K squared components so C1 which is now
squar C2 that is square C3 that is
squared and the cross products C1 and C2
C1 and C3 C2 and C3 right now what
happens to the weights these weights are
squared the weights corresponding to the
square components but the other ones are
cross interactions so if they were
negative at the beginning and both of
them are not negative then this is going
to be negative so in a sense you have a
mixture that allows for negative
parameters subtractions and therefore
this is square circuit is a non
monotonic
circuit so just a recap take a simple
sum a square it and now I have
essentially a quadratic number of
components if you think about that I
said before that increasing the number
of components increase expressiveness so
just doing this trick since I'm keeping
the number of parameters that I can
learn from data the same is still K but
now allow for a quadratic number of
components I already have a small boost
in expressivity
okay okay so this is going to be the
plan I would like to square um mixture
models and code it as non monotonic
circuits and actually the example I
showed you before comes from one of
these squared gaussian mixture models so
just pick a gaussian mixture model I let
the parameters to be negative and then I
Square it but here you seem to see only
two components where's the third comp
component for example doing the cross
interaction well it simply collapsed
into one of the
two so the model learned like to just
use a single positive component forget
about the third one and then subtract
essentially the middle
one this is a a gasan mixture model
squared starting from two
components okay now that you are in this
frame of mind you can think of well I
actually don't need the inputs to be
valid probability masses or densities
even a negative function will do and to
make Scot happy we can use polinomial
which are
amazing and play very well with this and
why do we want them
because we still have a small constraint
detail here and the fact is that if I
want to renormalize this whole guy I
need to compute the partition function
and what's the partition function of a
squar model is that this big
integral that is essentially
a quadratic number of integrals over
this cross products for people in
machine learning these are essentially
products of experts and what I want to
com being able to compute this partition
function efficiently and exactly the
dist trably is that these product of
experts are
tractable we are lucky such that for
example pols or other parametric
functions like
gaussians exponential families allow us
to do this analy ially
okay okay so that was the first part
subtraction mixture models they do exist
and if you square now we have a sort of
learning principle on how to keep the
negative parameters and potentially get
something more in terms of
expressiveness I want to go deeper not
just interested in small shallow mixture
models I want to have like deep circuits
right and square them all so how do we
do this well we need to introduce
products and as Robert was showing then
we can have like fairly deep circuits
okay as I was saying before the depth
allows you already to have an
exponential number of components right
when we square a circuit that is deep
then essentially we have a number of
components that this exponential in
twice the depth right but by adding the
negative components we can increase this
even
more so here's my problem for the next
five slides how do I efficiently Square
and therefore I want to renormalize a
deep
circuit any
idea stru compability
right some some kind voice from the back
says like the right answer and the the
right suggestion so we need certain
properties essentially to make sure that
the squared version of the circuit is
yet another circuit with smoothness and
decomposability the property we care
about my apologies for um efficient
renormalization but many of the people
in theoretical computer science would
know this algorithm as the apply
algorithm essentially now we are taking
two circuits and apply the product of of
operation among them right and to do
that as
the clever suggestion from the back from
I said we need that input it's not only
smoo decomposable it's smoo and
structure decomposable okay so if we do
this then the output is going to be
smooth and structure decomposable and
therefore this is efficient for
tractable renormalizing the
circuit now we also know from the
different application of apply that if
you want to compute the partition
function then we can do this linear in
the size of the square circuit and the
size of the square circuit is roughly or
better Loosely upper bounded by the
square of the size of the initial
circuit I'm stressing this out because
there is a nice Insight coming later on
from the tensorization point of
view so when I was writing the algorithm
in a previous paper when we were trying
to have like small atomic operations to
do all kinds of um operations over
circuits this was my multiply uh list I
could have like simplified it a bit and
actually doesn't cover many Corner cases
I had a student who point out at least
two Corner cases that are not covered in
this right so I put this here just to
make the point that if you don't want to
implement that yourself or even write
that yourself in
latch I'm might going to provide you
here a simplified version for the
squared algorithm where simplified means
you're not going to lose anything or
you're not going to gain anything in
terms of like complexity but you're
going to have like a better way to
understand the algorithm and a better
way to implement it if you really care
to put the circuit on the GPU for
example okay this is how the algorithm
is going to look like can still be
simplified a lot but it's basically a
bunch of linear algebra operation so how
do we get this so we need to do a little
bit of a leap if I manage to have you
here understanding this language of
circuits now there is a little bit of
leap of faith because now I need to tell
what's this slightly different notation
here right but once you get this
different notation then the squared
algorithm really really comes out very
intuitively so what's this guy here so
this is a way to tensorized the
structure decomposable pces that we need
to make the square we're g to abstract
them into layers and what do I mean by
that I'm going to take
many of the
units that I do have across the gra and
group them together according to their
Scopes and I'm going to color these
groups right such that later on I
exactly understand that they have the
same scope and they follow a certain
particular way to
decompose their their Scopes and this is
essentially the recipe behind um
variable orders V trees or region graphs
okay now if you do this for example in
this case you just have three units here
three other units here and then you join
them in products such that you do the
product the First with the first the
third with the third and so on so forth
instead for the sums you are allowed at
most to connect everything to everything
and if you put a PL um a weight to every
of these connections then essentially
you have a small metrix here if you keep
doing this for all the pieces of the
circuit essentially you just need to
keep track of these small layers and
their parameterization in Matrix
formulation this is quite useful if you
want to just map everything to the GPU
and if you want to multiply two
different circuits or Square a single
circuit that is structur
decomposable so in Vector notation I
just I have a vector of a certain length
let's say k another Vector of another
length k i do the Adar product which is
the element wise product and then I do
simply a matrix
multiplication and that's it and I'm
going to have as output a vector length
three that essentially collects the PDFs
or masses or intermediate results of my
circuit okay so every layer is a
vectorized um computation and then we
use parametrization by
matrices now as I was saying before this
helps you also understand very quickly
that if I have a region graph or a v
tree or a sudo
tree then every layer and every region
corresponds to one piece of this
structure here so let me also describe a
little bit what's going on here because
not this is not the usual V3 That You
observe this is a V3 defined over three
variables X1 X2 and X3 and this is a
partition that tells me that I have to
split X2 and X3 on one end and x one on
the other and then I keep partitioning
this guy here I don't know if you you
can appreciate that this is orange and
this is red and they're slightly
different into X3 and X2 and this is
exactly the recipe that I have in the
circuit here so in this circuit here I
have a layer that contains a bunch of
functions defined over X2 ands the color
and another bunch of functions over X3
ands the color then this product here
corresponds to the partition this
product layer and this some layer here
corresponds to this other region here
okay and I keep doing
this okay so this is not a so deep
circuit but is like fairly deep deep
enough for me not to waste too much time
to draw it and fit into fits into the
slide okay
now let's go back to the simple case to
give an intuition how to square the Deep
circuit in this format I was already
coloring things
before and grouping them in a sense then
we said that if I want to square a
shallow mixture model that is encoded as
a simple circuit whatever I need to do
is essentially squaring this layer and
putting a quadratic number of components
here and properly connect them by doing
the cross
products okay this a simple idea I need
to repeat for all possible layers in the
circuit so if I take a take a deep
circuit here which is structured
according to a variable order
partitioning region graph then this is
one I'm going to get it's the same
structure because the circuit is going
to be structur decomposable and as we
say compatible with the first one
they're going to share the same exact
region graph for V3 or sud Tre and
simply every layer is going to get
squared and by squaring I mean
introducing a quadratic number of
components I'm drawing them here as
squares for Simplicity but they are
vectors and then for the
parameterizations I'm just going to do
the quadr the chroner product with the
previous
ones and if you ask me this is a much
cleaner much simplified version to
understand the algorithm and to put that
on the GPU and it's very intuitive and I
always had trouble explaining people how
to essentially do the product of two
circuits same Machinery works if you
have two different circuits not the same
one you want to do the product together
and this is because they are color coded
in the same way that is essentially um
conforming to the same region graph
v33 okay now as I said before we know
this loose upper bound which is squared
in the size of the circuit right but if
we look at that from the perspective of
this kind of colored legal blocks
then I know that the size of the circuit
is basically the number of the layers
times the size of the
layers
right however I know that this Square
just correspond to squaring these layers
here so I'm not actually squaring the L
I'm simply like keeping the same number
of layers and I'm squaring the size of
the layers so this is
still a little bit um it's a tighter
upper bound so a much finer with this
than with the previous one helps me
better understand what's going on okay
so this is the product of the circuits
for those of you who do not know or
those of you who already knew just think
like a strange kind of apply over
circuits that encode functions and the
inputs that are not just literals and
that you can somehow group and and run
on the GPU okay okay so let's go to the
other step which other inference and
model classes they
support well well when we were doing
with he the first tutorial on
probabilistic circuit then we really
like to have this graphic for the
alphabet soup for all kinds of acronyms
in the tractable um probabilistic
modeling community so I'm super pleased
today to introduce more acronyms to this
mess but in a sense this is going to be
a good thing in the sense that we know
that we can connect them with the
literature we have in the circuit and
very
likely we can bring something that they
have in their communities in our
community right so the first one is the
family of the positive semi-definite
kernels they do represent the negative
functions which you can renormalize so
essentially a very good reip to model
tractable models tractable probabilistic
models and they work in these ways so
you pick like a kernel
function and you have um let's say d byd
positive semi-definite metric a
by the property of positive
semi-definiteness you know that the
function is always going to be non
negative no matter which values you get
here and you get here out of of your
kernels
okay now if you look at this might not
be super clear why this construction is
related to the squared circuits squared
non monotonic circuits that I try to
sell you up to
now and the reason it actually is
related is is quite simple you just do
an
SVD of the metrix and therefore you have
like a possibly low rank decomposition
and then you retrieve the squares into a
mixture so from this reduction
essentially in cubic time you go from a
PSD model to a squared a bunch of
squared non monotonic
circuits this community is very rich
they also have guarantees for example on
how to learn in terms of expressiveness
and and in in the rate of convergence
number of samples to learn these models
so it's quite a gold mine and we should
look into their literature a little bit
more second one it's an even larger
Community which might think it's even
larger perhaps than the circuit
community and spawns from quantum
mechanics physics and so so forth this
community you have even different names
for the same thing so you can call the
magx prodct state or a tensor train a
center factorization of a large D
dimensional tensor which goes by doing
several tensor contractions of your
sequence of tensors this is why it's
called a tensor
train well since we're doing just
constructions and sumon products it's
much easier to see that there is a
circuit here it's not immediate though
you need to do a little bit more and
massage this tensors and to retrieve
basically a computational graph that is
um a circuit that is structure
decomposable then people started to
square in them for different reasons and
for much better than um just wanted to
fit uh more complex models but this
actually comes from the born rule in
quantum mechanics and they call these
squared objects Bor machines and then
these guys here are basically another
family of structured decomposable non-
monotonic um circuit squared
circuits okay and if you look at them
their region graph is a tree again makes
sense because they're structure
decomposable but this what is called a
linear tree so a linear V tree if you
want doesn't really matter if it's right
linear or left linear but it's just
linear one and this is how you can
represent them in circuit after you
massage a little bit Those sensors it's
possible okay so so we get this Square
non monotonic circuits we get these
positive semi-definite kinal we get the
tensor networks what can we do with them
so if I just have a circuit that is
structur decomposable and smooth and
monotonic for example I can compute
marginal conditionals just by um in a
single fit forward pass of the circuit
as Robert showed in his slide
before what the non monotonic case I can
still do the same but in the size of the
squared circuit
for sampling we can sample exactly from
a smooth and decomposable circuit that
is monotonic thanks to also the seminal
work of Robert on latent variable
interpretation so it's pretty clear
what's the semantic of all these some
layers stacked one on top of the other
right now we do not
have um non- negative parameters anymore
our parameters are negative do we really
know
how to interpret these some units with
negative paret L Variables answer is no
not yet however we know how to sample
out of this in a simple Auto regressive
Way by inverse transform sampling so
since we can compute marginals and
conditionals we first um compute the
marginal CDF for a single variable and
we sample from that then conditional
value that we sample we sample for
another one and we keep doing that so
ideally we will need to evaluate this
for the size of the square circuit for
the number of variables we care
about if we play clever and we have a
balanced circuit then we can reduce this
to a logarithmic
time can we do
map well if monotonic circuit that are
smooth and decomposable we cannot do
that unless we add determinism
right however if we don't have
determinism we have juristic from um the
some product Network communities for
example or more beautiful algorithms
like U junks yesterday that you can
still use for
that can you still use these techniques
for non monotonic Square
circuits yes you just need to be more
careful because you are not propagating
just Maxes but since you have also
negative parameters you need to keep
track of both Max Maxes and um and and
means and minimums Al together but it's
possible so you can use this approximate
techniqu
however if this circuit were
deterministic you could do
this now the question is does it really
matter if this is deterministic do we
gain anything if this guy is
deterministic so let me switch to
another
topic expressivity let's keep this
question in mind what happens if my
circuit my original circuit see before
squaring is move structure decomposable
and
deterministic
and alternatively if you want do you
gain anything by squaring your
probabilistic version of obdds sdds and
structure decomposable
deterministic um decomposable uh
negation normal
forms any
ideas no well let's do the same
operation as before let's just do the
math so we start from this from the
previous guy and I want to compute the
cross interactions right however if this
amuni is deterministic by definition if
you remember Alexi definition
essentially all these inputs have this
joint supports which means that whenever
I compute the cross products they're
going to just cancel out always going to
be zero so you're never going to have
negative weights in the first place and
all the weights you have even if they
were negative at the beginning are going
to be B squared so you don't even get
the quadratic advantage of squaring the
deterministic
circuit no increas in size of the
circuit therefore no expressiveness and
no negative weights
okay however for what we are interested
in and for all the circuits I showed you
so far there was no determinism so we
are getting something out of that and
here's the lower bound where's the
battle okay as if I because there is
just machine learning people here
anyways okay here it goes there is a
class of functions of course in the
negative such that if I want to
represent them with the squared and non
monotonic circuit this is very tiny it's
very compact it's actually a shallow
mixture
model however the smallest monotonic and
structure decomposable circuit is going
to blow up in size okay how do I prove
this literally by using Alex's
techniques so we started from his paper
with Stefan and we made a rank
argument so here's the rank
argument we pick the function so at a
certain point I found this function and
I was looking at the function and then I
said this function is a squared circuit
and it's a squared non monotonic circuit
this function goes under the name of the
problem of Union of this
jointness and then it feel like the
perfect function for for uh proving the
the lower bound comes from the um Matrix
factorization Community actually if you
get the function and you know the
problem you know how to compute the rank
of the function and let it blow how do
you do this because you construct the
value metrics in the very same way that
Alexi was showing um two days ago I
think
okay and the same construction applies
so you can lower bound the size of the
circuit by the size of the summation
after you rewrite that as a
product of these decomposable functions
and then you have the lower bond for the
K that is essentially the rank of this
matrix it's quite simple and I did not
know about that let me know if you know
connections from your other lower bound
backgrounds okay but let all also ask
the problem in a more practical way it
is cool that there is this function and
tells us that there is an exponential
separation between the classes of models
right and on monotonicity brings us
something to the table when it comes to
learning we we actually get something I
really don't think that my data has been
generated by a function that Som related
to the union of these jness problems
okay so let's see what happens so I'm
going to give you first some intuition
with 2D data that helps you understand
what's going on first of all
synthetic data sets the one I showed you
before perhaps slightly more interesting
so here's the data here's what you can
get if you have a monotonic circuit
here's what you get if you square a
monotonic circuit and I want to do this
check because I want to disentangle the
two factors The increased expressiveness
I get just by squaring and increased
expressiveness I get just by introducing
negative parameters and in fact I'm also
compared with the Nom anatonic Square
circuit okay so for this very simple 2D
then is you see that just Square
squaring gets you something more because
you have more
components but you need negative
parameters for example to get rid of
some strange artifacts and get something
that is slightly
better I'm not sure if the you can
appreciate this uh through the projector
but some other
examples n monotonic better than n
monotonic Square better than monotonic
squar better than monotonic
okay that's this always
apply no why is that the case in
practice well whatever I showed you so
far assumes continuous variables but
what happens when we go to the
discrete imagine that our variables are
categorical distributions for a
categorical distribution even a mixture
model that is monotonic or just additive
just results in a categorical again you
don't gain anything even subtracting you
don't gain
much however if you're this because the
categorical is very powerful you have
degrees of freedom to capture anything
that is discrete with fin
States however if your base distribution
is more limited like the
binomial then having negative parameters
helps
more does it make some
sense okay find another interesting case
where in the discrete this helps greatly
more and this is where your variables
even if categorical have many more
States thousands of and in that case
subtracting might help at least from the
point of view of
learning let me jump to this case let me
address this plot here so this plot here
shows two curves one is for the squar
non monotonic the others is just for the
monotonic and I'm letting vary the
number of components that you can have
in every layer so the larger the more
exessive the circuit just by its
size and the data yeah I'm trying to fit
is data that I sampled from a large
language model gpt2 following for
example the the experiments by honga and
he and in this scenario your Laden
variables have lots of States because
you every variable encodes a token in a
sequence possible lots of tokens in in
in a position in a sequence right so in
this case there is a
gain on the other side
please to fairly compare would you have
to move the blue L like square roots to
the left like the iners cost the same
say that again so here for the same K
the inference cost is different for the
mod right so if you would normalize by
inference cost at the horizontal axis
you have to move the Blue Line closer so
the question
is what am I comparing here am I
comparing in terms of like cost or in
terms of like expressiveness that is
like learnable parameters like degrees
that you can fit this is for degrees
that you can fit in terms of or the
inference
times if that is what you mean like the
size of the materialized
circuit um you don't need to do that for
this plot you need to compare the
times essentially or if you want to
think of something that Rina would have
said if you have a budget in your memory
and what's the largest circuit you can
fit in the budget I will still argue
that something I didn't have time to
explain here that you actually don't
need to materialize the square circuit
you only need to do that when
renormalizing and you can do that only
once once the circuit is learned or only
once for every batch does it make some
sense okay can just Square the output
and okay here you have a bunch of other
data sets used in The Learning Community
for continuous data and I'm comparing
different input distributions gaussians
or polinomial plines and if you are in
the up quadrant squared circuits Square
non monotonic are better than monotonic
still holds for squared non monotonic
better than squared
monotonic we're looking like like like
likelihood yes likelihoods or log
likelihoods log likelihoods and and log
likelihoods in both
cases
okay how much time do I have
left sorry be very quick I should have
asked this question
before did on purpose then
smart Okay so open questions well it's
open question for example how to
retrieve this latent variable semantics
in this new class of circuit why do we
want that to have faster sampling but
also to have like better ways to train
for example by expectation
maximization I have some ideas but
that's super open to discuss this with
you if you're
interested then of course how do we
learn the structure and this also
belongs to the fact um that a lat
variable interpretation helps you also
learn the
structure and I'm thinking about
different ways of learning the structure
in a more mechanical hybrid mechanical
SL data driven
way then there are also many other
classes of circuits that we need to
connect and understand better if they're
really more expressive and to understand
if there are lower bounds that can work
in One Direction or another I think it's
still open in this
sense lastly I would think that we
really need to connect with the
community of quantum mechanics and
physics they are huge and they might
benefit a lot from what we're doing
especially the work on neuros symbolic
AI that Robert showed before treating
other circuits as The Logical circuit
imposing logical hard constraints I have
the feeling that's my personal
perspective from the other community
that they might not be looking into that
however there are lots of constraints
into the physics domain and constraints
perhaps not on just discrete variables
and button mixed continuous and
discret so for the people here
interested okay so to
recap I hope I capture a little bit of
your attention dear Watcher on
YouTube by by introducing a circuit
lower bound to play with also a new
class of tractable models to play with
showing that perhaps even just coloring
the way we tensorized circuits and which
is the way we Implement them ultimately
to run them on GPU helps us also
understand how to derive symbolic
algorithm
that are
simpler conceptually and drawing
connections across these old
communities that's it so let me just add
one more thing so all of this also falls
into the piece of trying to build an
automated way to have blocks such that
we can operate over intermediate oper
intermedia representation that are
circuits and automatically process
complex mathematical EX expression that
are essentially the queries we talked
about all these days and these negative
squared circuits can can play a role in
this um there are a bunch of results
that um come from this kind of approach
modular approach to query um reasoning
but we can discuss about this um later
on okay thank
[Applause]
you we don't actually have any time but
I guess we could
question sorry
for quick one about the structural
learning you mentioned that is an open
problem but what you what you did in the
experiments you just uh did in the
original circuit or I I did what we do
very commonly these days for
example um where did I have okay let's
say this for example I come up with a
region graph or V3 in a mechanized way
and then I populate the
circuit
by doing this essentially so for every
colored regions I put some units here
and there so these days we know for
example that you have options so you're
not limited to the construction of the
layers I showed you right now you can
put instead of another M product a
Kroner product instead of matrix
multiplication some crazier tensor
operation everything still holds but as
long as you keep this template that's
okay coming back to the structure
learning I would like to do two things
learn this from data by using the lat
variable interpretation for example if I
cluster the
data which kind of structure do I do I
get from here this happens in several
directions very old works like learn SPN
and more recent one like L and variable
distillations so clustering can help you
learn the structure also also pring it's
another form of structureal learning if
you want so what's the semantic now of
pring these kind of
edges so I have a question or maybe a
question for the
so so this is clearly more powerful and
it's really amazing than the monotone
structured circuits but they also feel
like uh there is still a lower Bound for
this model right so I think the
determinant doesn't have a multi-linear
polinomial size circuit so things like
dpps cannot actually be compactly
represented here so it's a really nice
sweet spot
between classic PCS and pgc's where you
have more tractability but still somehow
kind of the decomposability I think so I
remember reading your paper from angad
that was an open question If by having
negative parameters you can
represent
the distribution over the spanning trees
for example if you could unlock that
perhaps you have slightly more but still
like you so I'm not actually very sure
about what I'm saying but I'm looking at
the experts to maybe tell me over lunch
if if we need to GA the experts and they
are somewhere else no they're they're
here they're here okay
thanks